-Congratulations on the film.
You´re reprising your role
of Alfred the butler.
-Yeah.
-But you´re not very butlery
in this.
You´re very technologically
savvy, your Alfred.
-Yeah. Well, you know,
we wanted to move on.
When Zack Snyder took over
"Batman" as director,
we wanted to move on
from the silver tray
and the, you know, all of that
business, and the washing up.
And I --
I mean, the whole world is
getting more technological.
-Yeah.
-But I wanted to --
I suddenly remembered going to
dinner with John Paul Getty,
who I suppose -- he´s dead now.
Just about two years ago.
But he was a neighbor of mine in
England, and immensely wealthy.
I mean, he was an heir
to the Getty fortune.
Petrol, you know, gas.
And he had a bob or two.
And I remember arriving
in the car at his gate
and somebody very kindly
opened the door and I got out.
My wife got out, and they took
the car away, parked it.
And then I -- somebody opened
the gate into the garden
and I went through the garden.
Somebody opened -- another man
opened the front door.
And I went inside.
And there was another man
who took my coat,
took my wife´s coat,
and another man who stood there
with some champagne.
I get champagne.
And another man who opened
the doors into the party.
[ Light laughter ]
And I thought, you know,
"It´s wonderful."
They were all ex-S.A.S.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-So that´s like Special Forces?
-Okay.
-They were all there
to guard him.
-Oh.
-And I thought,
"That´s my Alfred."
-Oh, you wanted to be like
an Alfred who´s ex-military.
>> Yeah. That´s right.
He´s a guy who can sort of
do anything.
But also he can make you
a good cup of coffee.
-Oh, I see.
-But he has that history.
I mean, in the movie, of course,
the great thing about Alfred
is he doesn´t believe
in green screen.
-Oh, right.
So you don´t have to fight
anybody that´s not there.
You just work on a computer.
-That´s right.
I don´t have to fly.
I don´t have stand in front with
sort of --
you probably know how they do
green screen.
But it´s very tedious
for an actor.
Wonderful effects.
Amazing effects.
But I don´t have to do that.
I´m the guy at home.
And I´m very pleased about that.
-So you don´t mind that
you´re in a superhero movie
and you´re not doing
any superhero stuff.
-No, no.
-You´re basically Googling --
-Because I know --
I know the underneath.
-Oh, okay.
-You know, underneath.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
-Alfred is the...superhero.
-Oh, I see.
[ Laughter ]
-I know that.
-So we should go knowing...
-Yeah, yeah.
-...that the rest of
it´s all just a show.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Alfred´s the real guy.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Do you yourself--
are you tech-savvy?
-No.
-Okay.
-I know nothing about it.
-Nothing about it.
-No. I can get e-mails.
-Oh, congrats!
-And send them.
-Oh, wow, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. And I can --
I can do mobile phones.
-All right.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that is
how they work so...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I was going to ask --
you can do mobile phones?
Show me how they work.
[ Laughter ]
-But the other day
I had to call down to the hotel.
I was staying in a hotel.
I had to call down to see how
the VCR worked to get a DVD on.
I couldn´t do that.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Yeah.
I mean, I would say the
beginning is if it was a VCR,
that´s why
the DVD wasn´t working.
[ Laughter ]
You also, you know, we can see,
you know, you and Ben Affleck
were both in sort of
regular clothes,
but you don´t ever have to wear
the costume either.
-I don´t.
-Is that great?
-Oh, it´s wonderful!
We shot in the summer.
You know, and they´re all very
big people, apart from Gal,
who plays Wonder Woman.
But they´re very,
very big people, anyway,
but then they wear
these enormous costumes.
Sort of great, sort of
rubber things, you know.
Huge, which is sweltering.
-Yeah.
-Absolutely sweltering.
And, you know, I´m sitting there
in a shirt and sort of smiling.
But they have to --
when they stop acting,
they back up to
this sort of machine
and they´re plugged in,
and water, cold water,
is sent through the inside,
through pipes,
so it´s like a Frigidaire.
[ Light laughter ]
And it cools them down.
I don´t have to do that.
-Yeah, that´s wonderful.
I wonder if the real Batman
has to do that.
´Cause that makes him seem
a lot less cool, too.
-Yeah, well, I suspect he has to
do one or two things
we don´t know about.
-Yeah, that´s true.
That´s a good point.